everything we do has an impact on the
world around us
that can be a good thing or a bad one
for most of us that impact can seem
pretty small
if you throw an empty can on the ground
instead of in the recycling bin your
local park will still be pretty clean
those actions can add up though what if
everyone you know decides to start
throwing their trash on the ground too
or a nearby factory decides to dump all
of their trash there
as the human population of earth grows
we tend to consume and throw away more
and more natural resources
this trash bio is a simple example of
pollution which can also refer to toxic
particles in our air or waterways
human activities are also contributing
to more complex problems like
overfishing or deforestation which can
drive wildlife to extinction and disrupt
the natural processes that keep our
planet running smoothly
let's take a look at a real place that's
facing some of these complex
environmental problems
this is like irmia in iran once the
largest lake in the middle east and the
sixth largest saltwater lake on earth
the lake was a popular destination for
people who wanted to visit its uniquely
salty shores as well as for migratory
birds like flamingos and pelicans who
had stopped at a rest during their long
journeys this satellite image of lake
ermia is from 1984. now compare it to
another image taken in 2018 in just a
few decades the lake has shrunk
dramatically what happened well around
the 1980s iran needed to create new jobs
and sources of food for its growing
population more people began moving near
lake irmia converting large portions of
the landscape into agricultural fields
they tried growing profitable new crops
like apples watermelon and sugar beets
but many of these plants require a lot
more water than the dry climate could
provide
so people built dams across many of the
rivers that flowed into the region so
they could more easily transport fresh
water to their fields and communities
iran has always experienced droughts but
with people using up so much water the
impact of these droughts became much
worse lake irmia began to shrink the
remaining water became so salty that
many aquatic fish and other small
critters couldn't survive leaving
migratory birds and other wildlife
without a source of food sandstorms blew
salt from the dry lake bed over
agricultural fields making it even
harder for people to grow food during
droughts
farmers were forced to move away and
many others from the tourist towns
followed since few wanted to visit a
vanishing lake where people could get
sick from breathing the salty air at one
point lake irmia lost nearly 90 percent
of its historical volume and many of its
once thriving communities turned into
ghost towns there's no question that
human activities from unsustainable
farming practices to diverting water
flow caused this environmental
catastrophe human activities aren't
always negative though we can work
together to design technologies that
monitor and minimize our harmful impacts
since environmental problems are often
so complex we need to consider a lot of
different things to create sustainable
solutions what does scientific research
tell us about this place and how it's
changing what are the needs desires and
values of the people affected by this
problem both as individuals and as a
society
are there any constraints or challenges
that could prevent us from taking action
despite economic and political
constraints many iranians support
efforts to save lake ermia which has
encouraged leaders to provide more
funding and other restoration resources
key parts of the ecosystem are now
protected by reserves or national parks
researchers have introduced new farming
practices to the region such as planting
less thirsty pomegranate trees or
watering crops at night to prevent
evaporation this has allowed farmers to
save water while still producing enough
food finally engineers have been
building new technologies that transfer
water from surrounding areas into the
lake
even with all of these changes the
problems plaguing lake ermia aren't
completely fixed yet wildlife habitats
still need to be restored so aquatic
species can survive and migratory birds
can fuel up for their long journeys
water levels are still too low to
attract many tourists and salt from the
exposed lake bed can still harm people's
health when kicked up during sand storms
people are worried that transferring
water into lake ermia from nearby
regions may cause even more widespread
water shortages their needs and concerns
need to be addressed for decisions to
work properly in the long term
while there's still plenty left to do
these efforts combined with a few good
rain years have allowed lake ermia to
return to about half of its historical
size
check out this google earth image from
2022 it's not back to the way it was but
it's looking a bit better
lake irmia isn't the only lake on earth
that's under threat from human
activities for example the great salt
lake in the united states is also
shrinking for very similar reasons
shared challenges can provide
opportunities for people to share
solutions people can learn from what
others are doing to fix similar problems
or even brainstorm new ideas
for example researchers from iran and
the united states have started working
together to compare conservation
activities on both of their salt lakes
even though they're half a world apart
while human action often has a negative
impact on the planet we have the power
to spark positive change too if you feel
like your actions alone are too small to
make a difference against a big problem
whether it's a shrinking lake or a giant
pile of garbage in your neighborhood
there's usually a few other concerned
citizens that would be happy to help
find a solution